and funerals are taking place across
Afghanistan's hurat Province after a
devastating earthquake struck the
country on Saturday a Taliban
spokesperson said more than 2,400 people
were killed in the 6.3 magnitude
earthquake six Villages were destroyed
and hundreds of civilians buried under
the debris it's one of the deadliest
earthquakes to strike the country in two
decades and the Quake struck a densely
populated area near Afghanistan's fourth
largest city survivors of Saturday's
deadly Quake were rushed to hospitals
some of them were pulled alive from the
rubble many of our family members have
been martyred including one of my sons
and my other son is also injured most of
the people are under the rubble I don't
know anything about my mother my
daughter my son whether they are dead or
alive